- [Voiceover] We've seen
in several videos so far
that most of the waves that
humans have encountered
in nature--waves in
the water, sound waves,
or just waves traveling along a rope--
they were disturbances
traveling through a medium.
And so when light displays
or has wave-like properties
a very natural assumption
was, well, light must
also be a disturbance
traveling through some type of a medium
even if that medium
wasn't so easy to detect.
But they conjectured that
there is some type of medium
that light is disturbance
traveling through.
They called it the luminiferous ether.
And much of physics in the 19th century
was all around proving that
the luminiferous ether existed
and also figuring out what
our relative velocity was
in regards to that luminiferous ether.
And why do we feel confident,
or why did they feel confident,
that there was a relative velocity?
Well, we talked about
that in the last video.
The earth is spinning and
then it's spinning around,
it's orbiting around,
the sun at a nice clip
and then the whole
solar system is orbiting
around the center of the
galaxy at a nice clip.
The galaxy itself might be moving,
so if you have some
absolute frame of reference
that's defined by the ether,
well we are going to be
moving relative to it.
And if we're moving relative to it
well maybe you just
measure the speed of light
in different directions and
see whether the speed of light
is faster or slower in a certain direction
and then that might help you identify--
well, one, validate
that the ether exists--
but also think about what our velocity is
relative to the ether,
relative to that absolute
frame of reference.
But the problem in the 19th century
is that we didn't have any precise way
of actually measuring--or
a precise enough way
of measuring--the speed of
light where we could detect
the relative difference
due to the light going
for or against, or into or away from,
the actual direction of the ether wind.
And so the experiment
that is usually cited
with first kind of breaking things open,
starting to really make
a dent in this whole idea
of a luminiferous ether, is the
Michelson-Morley Experiment.
They recognized, okay, we can't
measure the speed of light
with enough precision to detect
has it gotten slowed down
by the ether wind or sped
up by the ether wind,
but what we could do,
and this is what Michelson
and Morley did do,
and I'm gonna do an
oversimplification of the experiment,
is that, okay, you have a light source,
you have a light source right over here.
So, you have a light source.
And so that's going to send
light in this direction.
It's going to send light just like that.
And what you do is you
have a half-silvered mirror
that allows half the light
to pass directly through it
and half of it to be reflected.
So let's put a half-silvered
mirror right over here.
So, there's a half-silvered mirror.
And so half of this light
will bounce off like this,
and this is just a simplification of it.
Let me do it a little neater than that.
So half will bounce off like that.
And then the other half will
be able to go through it.
Will be able to go through it.
It's a half-silvered mirror.
And then we make each
of those light rays--
we've essentially taken
our original light ray
and split it into two--
well then we'll then
bounce those off mirrors.
Bounce those off mirrors
that are equidistant.
And there are some adjustments
when you actually have
to factor in everything,
but just as a simple notion,
these things are just
now going to bounce back.
So, this one is now going to bounce back.
It's half-silvered, it can go through,
or part of it can go through, that mirror.
So that's that ray.
And then this one is going to bounce back.
This one's going to go bounce back.
And part of it is going to
bounce into this direction.
And then you can detect what you see.
You can detect what you see.
So this right over here is a detector.
And you might be saying
okay, Sal, well what's the big deal?
You've taken a light
source, you've bounced,
you've split the light rays,
you've put them back together,
you've bounced them around a little bit.
But think about if there
was a luminiferous ether
these light waves that are
going in orthogonal directions
will be going at different velocities.
Let's say if that luminiferous ether,
if that luminiferous ether
wind was doing something
like, let me see, if the ether wind
were in this direction,
if the ether wind were in that direction,
when the light wave is going that way
it should be going faster,
and when the light wave
is coming back it should be going slower.
And so what Michelson and
Morley did is they said
okay, let's assume...
let's adjust our
apparatus right over here,
so when then these two
lights rays bounce off
and come back together,
if there were no ether
you would have some basic
interference pattern.
So, what do I mean by
interference pattern?
Well let's say that
you have maybe this one
bouncing from up here.
Let me do that in a different color.
So the one bouncing from up here,
the one bouncing from up here,
let's say that looks like this.
I'll just draw it as a longitudinal wave,
just like this.
Best I had in hand-drawn
longitudinal wave.
And then the one coming
from the other direction,
the one that bounces here,
and then comes back like this,
is another longitudinal wave, like this.
And when they overlap they
are going to interfere
with each other, either
constructively interfere
or destructively interfere.
So you could have something like this.
So let me copy and then let me paste it.
So depending on how far or how fast
each of these traveled,
you're going to have
different levels of interference.
And you would have a difference,
depending on the orientation,
depending on what the
actual ether wind is doing.
But what Michelson and Morley observed
is that no matter how they
oriented this apparatus,
and they did it at
different times of the year,
and they rotated it
around, and they rotated it
in the vertical direction
and the horizontal direction,
no matter what they did
they always got the same
interference pattern.
The interference pattern did not change.
And because the interference
pattern did not change
it implied that well, maybe this ether
isn't really having an
effect on slowing down
or speeding up the light waves.
So this is often called
one of the most famous
failed experiments in physics.
So let me write this down.
What's powerful about it is
that it was a failed experiment.
Let me get my pen tool out.
It was a failed, failed experiment
but it made people start to question
well, maybe there isn't an ether,
a luminiferous ether, maybe
light just somehow travels
through the vacuum.
Maybe there is not this
absolute frame of reference
that's defined by the luminiferous ether.
And I wanna be clear, it wasn't
this experiment by itself.
This experiment was one of many
that started to put that doubt.
But even after this experiment
and they saw that there was no change
in the interference pattern no matter how
they oriented this thing,
whether is was going
in the direction of the
hypothetical luminiferous ether
or away from it, whatever,
when they say no matter
how they oriented it
they got the same interference patterns,
people tried to come up
with other explanations
that still might have been
okay with a Luminiferous Ether.
Maybe the length got contracted
in the direction of the motion.
Maybe other things got affected.
But this is a super important
experiment in physics
because, once again, it started to show
that hey, maybe there is
no luminiferous ether,
that light is just gonna
go through that vacuum
and, as we'll see, is
going to be traveling
at the same velocity no matter what
frame of reference you look at it from.
But we'll explore that
more in future videos.